[Musik]
schön dass sie dabei sind liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer herzlich
willkommen zu einer besonderen ausgabe
von hallo deutschland einem hallo
deutschland spezial bei dem es um ihre
fragen geht zum krieg in der ukraine
gemeinsam mit verschiedenen expertinnen
und experten suchen wir nach antworten
und stichwort gemeinsam ich freue mich
sehr dass ich diese besondere sendung
mit dem moderieren darf alice alice der
jungen herzlich willkommen du bist von
der delft live und hier mit dabei und
vor allem schön wenn sie jetzt mit dabei
sind und vor allem mitmachen sie können
uns live fragen stellen im stream direkt
bei youtube facebook oder per mail an
ihre fragen eher zdf de die stellen wir
dann direkt hier in der sendung unseren
expertinnen und experten die finden dann
antworten und team und ich wir haben
dass also die ganze zeit über hier im
blick und außerdem und dass es auch neu
geht unsere sendung nach 18 uhr online
noch für sie weiter also außergewöhnlich
viel sendezeit für ein ja
außergewöhnliches thema auch am tag 12
des krieges in der ukraine ist die
bestürzung ist die fassungslosigkeit
über die russischen angriffe unverändert
hinzu kommt die angst dass sich der
krieg weiter ausbreiten könnte ja das
vielleicht sogar einen atomkrieg droht
diese menschen fliehen um ihr leben
während russische truppen weiter auf
kiew zu steuern wird außerhalb der
hauptstadt gekämpft und bombardiert der
bevölkerung bleibt nichts anderes übrig
als zu flüchten über die zerstörten
straßen ihrer heimat
obwohl der krieg lemberg im westen noch
nicht direkt erreicht hat ist ein
kinderkrankenhaus schon überfüllt mit
kranken und verletzten kindern
sie sind müde
traumatisiert und voller angst
ich habe ein flugzeug gehört ich konnte
in der nacht überhaupt nicht schlafen
ich habe nur versucht mich zu verstecken
mein onkel wurde am kopf getroffen
[Musik]
gute freunde von uns in den haag ist
einige von ihnen werden sicherlich
sterben
auch in lemberg steigt die angst vor der
invasion stundenlang stehen zivilisten
vor waffengeschäften an sie wollen sich
und ihre familien schützen sagen sie
wenn es soweit kommt der westen liefert
während dessen unterstützung unter
anderem in form von waffen an die
ukraine russland aber waren vor einer
einmischung der nato vor gut einer woche
wurde als antwort auf westliche
sanktionen und die ankündigung von
waffenlieferungen der befehl gegeben die
russischen atomstreitkräfte in erhöhte
alarmbereitschaft zu versetzen der
zweite schritt in einem vierstufigen
atom stufenplan ein gezielter angriff
durch atomwaffen scheint jedoch nicht
die einzige nukleare bedrohung des
krieges zu sein ukrainische behörden
hatten vergangene woche einen angriff
auf europas größtes atomkraftwerk
gemeldet mittlerweile ist es unter
russischer kontrolle die gefahr vorerst
gebannt
tatjana kommt aus der nähe des
kraftwerks
ich hatte große angst als sie beim werk
in sabrina geschossen haben nicht wegen
mir sondern wegen meines kindes also
habe ich mich entschlossen zu gehen
wie zahlreiche andere aus dem ganzen
land wartet sie jetzt in lemberg auf
einen zug der sie aus dem land und aus
der unmittelbaren gefahr bringen soll
die angriffe und belagerung der
atomkraftwerke in der ukraine das macht
vielen sorgen dass der russische
präsident putin eben selbst vor dem
einsatz von atomwaffen nicht
zurückschreckt darüber können wir jetzt
sprechen mit professor marina henkel sie
ist sicherheitsexperten an der hertie
school von berlin schön dass sie bei uns
in frau henke hallo hallo und frau henke
die erste frage die wäre da natürlich
wie groß schätzen sie diese gefahr ein
tatsächlich ja es gibt hier zwei
gefahren und es gibt eben die gefahr
eines unfalls eines atomkraftwerks oder
beziehungsweise den beschuss eines
atomkraftwerks und dann wirklich
atomwaffen ich denke nicht dass putin
eine strategie hat atomkraftwerke direkt
anzugreifen weil der schaden hier
russland selbst betreffen wird die
russische armee rückt vor die
verseuchung eines atomkraftwerkes würde
vor allem die ukraine betreffen und so
müssten praktisch sich die russen darum
auch kümmern aber ja es könnte
existieren dass putin eine politische
eine militärische strategie hat er
taktische nuklearwaffen zu benutzen
genau das ist ja auch das was ich gerade
angesprochen haben in bezug auf vladimir
putin und da passt dort die erste frage
einer unserer zuschauer zu die zu diesem
thema ein kamerateam gedreht hat das ist
die frage nämlich von birgit münzenmaier
zu diesem thema
wieder an den tisch an den
verhandlungstisch bringen
ohne dass beide seiten ihr gesicht
verlieren
ja ohne dass beide seiten ihr gesicht
verlieren und vor allem überhaupt
erstmal wieder zurückbringen an den
verhandlungstisch können sie da noch mal
ihre einschätzung geben das ist ja eines
ihrer spezialgebiete diese krisenzeiten
diese konflikt phasen wie man damit
umgeht ganz genau also 13 arien sind
gerade plausibel das erste szenario ist
dass im endeffekt russland diese
kampagne gewinnt das kann sehr brutal
sein aber man kann vielleicht zur
kapitulation der ukraine
führen das zweite szenario ist dass es
einen gibt in russland und hier würde
man erwarten dass das neue regime
daneben die truppen zurückzieht und dann
würde man verhandeln bzw das wäre auch
das ende des konfliktes und das dritte
szenario was hier die frau angesprochen
hat sind verhandlungen und hier gerade
heute hat russland einen einen neuen
forderungskatalog vorgestellt jetzt sind
gibt es vier forderungen die erste
forderung ist dass zielinski zwar
präsident bleiben davon der ukraine aber
die russen möchten ein premierminister
einsetzen den sie aussuchen die zweite
forderung ist dass die verfassung von
der ukraine vorschreibt dass die ukraine
niemals die eu oder der nato beitritt
die dritte forderung ist dass die
ukraine sowohl die separatisten gebiet
im donbass als auch die krim anerkennt
und wenn man schon sieht das sind das
sind sehr große forderungen und gerade
denke ich nicht dass die ukraine bereit
ist dem hier zuzustimmen aber man kann
sich natürlich vorstellen wenn mehr und
mehr zivilisten sterben das so der der
wille von den ukrainerinnen gebrochen
wird
forderungen oder vielmehr natürlich auch
hoffnungen und wünsche haben natürlich
auch die menschen in der ukraine die
versuchen sich mit allen mitteln zu
verteidigen und kämpfen für ihre
freiheit und der ukrainische präsident
er fordert in seiner not nun auch noch
eindringlicher dass die eu sein land als
mitglied aufnimmt und dazu haben wir
eine frage bei youtube ansehen die kommt
von l jansen ich lese sie mal ganz kurz
vor er oder sie möchte gerne wissen was
würde sich mit dem eu beitritt der
ukraine in der jetzigen situation ändern
und wird das eilverfahren rund um den
beitritt der ukraine bewusst von der eu
herrn hinausgezögert was sagen sie dazu
also es gibt im den lissabon verträgen
ganz spezielle kriterien die erfüllt
werden müssen damit ein land der
europäischen union beitreten kann und
das sind ganz oft sehr sehr lange
verfahren also wenn ich hier gerade an
slowenien denke oder auch an die
baltischen staaten das hat wirklich
mehrere jahre manchmal sogar jahrzehnte
gedauert bis diese staaten der
europäischen union beigetreten sind und
deshalb denke ich wirklich dass es in
diesem moment nicht möglich ist so ein
schnellverfahren hierdurch durchzuführen
aber natürlich man könnte sich
vorstellen dass man der ukraine die
perspektive gibt der eu beizutreten
glauben sie denn dass das sinn macht
oder dass das ausreicht in dieser phase
da gibt es nicht sehr viele fragen wo
die leute sagen dass die sorge einfach
viel viel größer ist als das was sie
gerade auch geschildert haben nämlich
wie auf facebook gerade michaela tod
schreibt die wohl größte sorge ist dass
wir in russland nicht an der grenze zu
polen stoppt sondern weitergeht sind wir
wirklich bereit uns zu verteidigen
abzüglich der möglichkeiten dies per
verhandlungen gäbe sind wir wirklich
bereit uns zu verteidigen
also sobald russland ein nato staat
eingreift kommt der artikel 5 von nato
ins spiel und das heißt praktisch auch
dass die usa und dann verteidigt und
insgesamt mit amerika also alle
nato-staaten zusammen haben schon eine
chance sich zu verteidigen gegenüber
russland wenn man diese mit
konventionellen waffen also nicht
atomaren waffen anschaut dann ist nato
sogar um einiges stärker als russland
aber ich hoffe und ich bete dass es dazu
nicht kommt
hoffen und beten und bangen wir auf
jeden fall mit und auch viele unserer
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer denn wenn
man sieht was reinkommt alisa geht das
ja genau in die richtung die sorge ist
groß und vor allen dingen auch eben die
frage wie kann es gelöst werden genau es
gibt hier eine frage die kampagne von
silke die fragt sich was würde passieren
wenn die ukraine den forderungen putins
nachkommen würde und sich
entmilitarisierten würde wäre eine
kapitulation eine möglichkeit um das
leid der zivilisten zu minimieren
im prinzip würde ich sagen ja es wäre
eine möglichkeit
putin hat ganz klar gesagt er möchte die
entmilitarisierung von ukraine er möchte
die entnazifizierung aber da sieht man
jetzt dass er da sogar ein bisschen
flexibilität gezeigt hat also er würde
sie lenski erlauben präsident zu bleiben
aber es gibt eben dann diesen deputy
posten denen die russen besetzen möchten
so also zu sagen aber was man wirklich
gesehen hat in der ukraine ist ein
unglaublicher patriotismus ein
kämpfergeist und ich kann mir einfach
nicht vorstellen dass sie dass die
ukrainische bevölkerung einfach so ein
de facto von russland kontrolliert das
regime akzeptieren wird und deshalb
denke ich dass es
irgendwann eben zu einem interaktions
krieg kommen wird dass man sich eben
dann doch gegen diese dieses russische
regime wert und diese switches russische
regime wird angeführt von wladimir putin
und nachdem wird natürlich auch öfter
gefragt egal ob per e mail oder auf
anderen online kanälen dann jeder müller
fragt wieso ist putin angeblich nicht
ausfindig zu machen wir sind doch heute
so gut technisiert und versetzt wieso
wissen wir nicht wo die waffen
stationiert sind und warum ist er selber
eben nicht dingfest zu machen
ja ich weiß leider auch nicht wo putin
ist es kann sein dass es geheimdienste
gibt die es wissen natürlich hatte er
eine terrasse daran in den winkeln sich
zu verstecken man könnte sich auch
vorstellen dass er eben vielleicht auch
furcht hat vor einem akku aber gerade
ist es wirklich unglaublich schwierig
abzuschätzen was da in moskau was in
diesen
regierungskreisen vor sich geht und
vielleicht ist putin auch gar nicht in
moskau sondern
anstatt aber ich persönlich weiß es
leider nicht danke frau professor henke
bis hierhin wir können später noch
weiter sprechen mit ihnen online ja
vielen dank und bis später und ja wohl
niemand von uns allen kann sich davon
frei machen dass er oder sie angst hat
in diesen tagen selbst die
außenministerin hat gestern abend offen
zugegeben in einem interview hier im zdf
dass auch ihr und ihrem team manchmal
die knie schlotterten natürlich die
jeder einzelne anders damit um aber fest
steht die angst die angst ist
allgegenwärtig
damals mit dem jugoslawienkrieg da man
ja auch sehr nahe da war ich jetzt noch
jugendliche da hat man ja schon bedenken
körperlich denselben schon mitgemacht
habe diese situation wo also wo alles
kaputt war und das vergisst man nicht
ich werde dafür beten dass nicht so weit
kommt ich bin katholisch und musste so
dass das ganze ganz schlimme sache weg
die angst geht um in deutschland die
angst dass der krieg in der ukraine sich
ausweitet im schlimmsten fall zu einem
atomkrieg
kriegs ängste führen dazu dass so dass
grundlegende sicherheitsgefühl massiv
erschüttert wird und insbesondere bei
lebens älteren männern und frauen die
einen krieg schon mal miterlebt haben
die haben ganz reale ängste weil sie
genau wissen wie schrecklich das ganze
ist was mit menschen passiert und jeder
mensch fühlt anders irgendwo zwischen
angst und zuversicht gerade wenn es um
eine mögliche ausweitung des ukraine
krieges geht hat den luftkrieg mit
midnight das ist mein angst nein ich
sehe keine kriegsgefahr auf uns zukommen
obwohl die medien die kriegsangst türen
und auch die eine oder andere person
verunsichern also ich verstehe die
ängste glaube das allerdings nicht weil
nach wie vor die nato und auf einigen
der gegenseitigen beistand die man sich
ja in der nato gewährt
ein ausreichender schutz hier ist also
deswegen ich denke nicht dass wir das in
deutschland fürchten das gilt auch für
die kinder gerade nach dem zweijährigen
einschränkungen im zusammenhang mit
corona es hat einige kinder verwirrt und
beängstigend
beängstigt fragen sich viele eltern wie
geht man mit so einer situation um die
kinder kriegen das jahr mit ich habe
eigentlich größte sorge um die nächste
generation also meine kinder und meine
enkelkinder in was für eine welt sieht
abgeraten
das ist die große frage die wir jetzt
lernen wollen denn bei uns im studio ist
professor borwin bandelow als psychiater
und psychologen an der uni göttingen und
darin auch experte für angststörungen
den umgang mit angst herzlich willkommen
und wie machen sie das denn sozusagen
als fachmann für ängste für sorgen ganz
persönlich falls sie welche haben in
diesen tagen wie gehen sie damit um mit
dem was sie beängstigt oder besorgt ich
bin auch besorgt also die schlaf
manchmal schlecht wacht nachts auf und
grübelt wie es weitergeht
und es gibt ja
eigentlich zwei strategien sind mir
eingefallen einmal ich schalte alle
medien ab und hört überhaupt nicht mehr
hin und gehen garten und bereitete den
auf das frühjahr vor ort andere
strategie werde mich zu informieren und
ich glaube das ist die bessere strategie
dass man sich immer in den medien
informiert auch viel mit anderen leuten
redet darüber und auf jeden fall jetzt
sich verkriechen davor sondern sich
immer informieren und auch mit freunden
bekannten verwandten darüber zu sprechen
und das eine schließt das andere ja
nicht aus
man muss es einfach auch mal stoppt sein
ist es so viel geht mir persönlich auch
so aber dass ich jetzt nicht den garten
frühlingsfest machen sondern hier bei
uns sind das freut uns helfen es geht
auch vielen unserer zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer so wir haben per mail von
andreas eine ja sein seine stimmung
beschrieben bekommt man auch eine frage
er schreibt ich fühle mich seit tagen
schlecht denn ich kann mir immer noch
gemütlich eine pizza bestellen in der
ukraine sterben die menschen die kann
ich damit am besten umgehen ja es ist
tatsächlich dass viele leute ist ein
schlechtes gewissen haben wir freuen uns
jetzt auf einen mehr oder weniger corona
freien sommer und es sterben die
menschen in der ukraine und viele so das
gefühl was kann ich tun außer vielleicht
etwas zu spenden aber so das macht ein
so ohnmächtig nicht aber trotzdem muss
man sagen ihr habt das nicht gemacht das
ist wladimir putin das angestellt hat
und nicht die menschen die jetzt in
deutschland noch ganz gut leben
doch im vorfeld haben wir menschen
gefragt was ihre fragen sind was sie
beschäftigte schauen wir mal kurz rein
also was mich als familienvater aktuell
umtreibt ist wie erkläre ich die
aktuelle situation in der ukraine also
den krieg meinen kindern es ist einfach
so dass man momentan einfach das gefühl
hat man kann nicht mehr atmen also es
ist ja immer irgendetwas anders die
letzten zwei jahre und sobald man meint
es einige zu ende kommt das nächste und
man wird gerne mal wieder tief
durchatmen können und es ist einfach
schwierig im moment für mich definitiv
für ich haben sie auch gerade selber
angesprochen herr bandelow ist es denn
dann legitim wenn das so ausgedrückt
wird durch die fragen um jetzt immer
zuerst zu beantworten dass man trotzdem
einfach mal was anderes macht in den
garten gehen pizza bestellen nachrichten
ausmachen und an sich denkt ja das ist
tatsächlich so weil menschen gewöhnt
sich nach einer gewissen zeit auch auf
so eine bedrohungslage selbst wenn die
dann auch weiter besteht aber im moment
sind wir wirklich in der ersten phase wo
es extrem vielen menschen also nach
umfragen mindestens 75 prozent der
menschen denken dass das in uns
irgendwann auch nochmal betreffen wird
also dass der krieg sich vielleicht
ausweiten könnte also das ist schon
heftig angst die die menschen überall
haben und das ist das hält oft lange an
ein paar wochen aber dann würden sich
menschen muss man sagen an die angst
weil sie adaptieren
da noch mal ganz kurz die nachfrage wenn
sie sagen es kann eben auch zu uns rüber
starten das ist ja eine große sorge wie
erkläre ich dass den kindern das war ja
gerade die frage alisa die duh
anmoderiert hast wie macht man das wenn
die bedrohung trotzdem reales ja die
kinder kriegen ja alles mit und man die
erwachsenen sollen nicht denken dass sie
kindern dass man das denn am besten
alles verschweigt dann machen sie sich
ihre eigenen gedanken und das können
daneben schlimme albträume seien die
idee kinder haben also besser ist es
dass man mit den kindern darüber redet
natürlich nicht so dass sie dann völlig
verängstigt sind und denken dass nächste
woche die russen hier stehen aber dass
man ihn möglichst erklärt was im moment
dort abläuft in eine altersgerechte
sprache und sie aber auf der anderen
seite auch wieder beruhigt ganz wichtig
am ende ich muss noch einmal aufgreifen
mir lesen schon das ist das was am
meisten beschäftigt also laura frank die
beschreibt auch ich denke den ganzen tag
an nichts anderes als bomben die mittel-
und westeuropa sofort zunichte machen
könnte ich habe zwar großes mitleid mit
den ukrainern ukrainerin aber unfassbar
angst um meine familie und mich in
deutschland sowie alle europäer ich
fühle mich nicht ausreichend hierzu
informiert kann ich meinen alltag unter
dieser ich kann meinem alltag unter
diese angst nicht mehr normal nachgehen
also immer wieder dieser zwiespalt das
kommt öfter mit dem alltag nachgehen und
gleichzeitig aber im party schon
informiert bleiben wie kann das
funktionieren
ja das ist tatsächlich so dass manche
leute sich zum beispiel
vielleicht fühlen wenn sie jetzt auf
eine party gehen und um fröhlich mit den
freunden feiern und das ist natürlich
betrifft sehr viele leute im moment
es ist natürlich so es bringt natürlich
jetzt nichts wenn wir uns jetzt noch
mehr angst machen als es ohnehin schon
notwendig ist also man sollte versuchen
erstmal noch mal versuchen zum normalen
tagesablauf überzugehen und auch jetzt
wissen wir dass wahlkarten corona gerade
mal so noch nicht ganz überstanden aber
dass wir das jetzt mal noch mal
irgendwie ausnutzen dass es uns da
vielleicht in dieser richtung besser
geht und da sollen wir dann auch ganz
schlechtes gewissen haben und dass sie
uns dafür mut machen und so viele sachen
erklärt haben in der kürze zeit dafür
bedanken wir uns ganz ganz herzlich herr
bandelow für den besuch hier in mainz
und das ist so wie ich die dieser umgang
mit der angst mit der bedrohung jemand
wie sie zu haben der uns dadurch leitet
dankeschön danke
und viele von uns haben in den letzten
tagen auch selbst darüber nachgedacht
was es bedeuten muss das eigene zuhause
von eben auf gleich verlassen zu müssen
so wie es den menschen in der ukraine
eben geht sie müssen plötzlich fliehen
und wie ist das wenn das eigene leben
plötzlich in einen rucksack passen muss
ungewiss ob man jemals zurückkehren kann
mehr als 1,5 millionen menschen sind
inzwischen bereits geflohen etliche
familien wurden dabei
auseinandergerissen und zigtausende sind
nun in deutschland auch angekommen unter
anderem viele von ihnen in berlin der
flüchtlingsstrom reißt nicht ab berlins
hauptbahnhof entwickelt sich immer mehr
zum zentralen anlaufpunkt in deutschland
über 13.000 menschen aus der ukraine
sollen allein gestern gekommen sein die
stadt kommt an ihre grenzen immer
häufiger werden betroffene mit
reisebussen direkt nach ihrer ankunft in
andere bundesländer gebracht
wir wären gern in berlin geblieben uns
wurde aber gesagt alles ist belegt wo
anders soll es noch freie plätze geben
wir sind mit einem kleinkind hier und
wollen einfach nur zur ruhe kommen auch
berlins erstaufnahmestelle für
flüchtlinge stellt sich auf mehr
transporte einbusse sind es auch hier
die für mehr entlastung sorgen sollen
wusste die hier ankommen und geflüchtete
dann für den weitertransport etwa
nach saarland aber auch nach
nordrhein-westfalen abnehmen und in den
kommenden tagen hier mit einer weiteren
zunahme dieser drehscheiben aktivität zu
rechnen ist im zwischengeschoss des
hauptbahnhofes geht die arbeit für die
freiwilligen helfer aber unvermindert
weiter essensausgabe bereitstellen von
sanitärartikeln und vor allem immer
wieder fragen beantworten manche sind
seit tagen im einsatz sie spüren dass
die kräfte nachlassen
ja man ist müde aber wir müssen einfach
mit bar kann also wir müssen dieser
menschen helfen ich kann mir das nicht
anders vorstellen dass du denn hier alle
mittlerweile wird vor dem bahnhof eine
neue anlaufstelle errichtet die
stadtmission soll in dem zelt
federführend geflüchtete betreuen
besonders besorgt ist die
hilfsorganisation das jetzt unbegleitete
minderjährige häufiger beobachtet werden
zahl besonders bedürftige könnte weiter
steigen wir müssen auch davon ausgehen
dass jetzt wo auch schutz korridor
geschaffen werden aus den umkämpften
gebieten dass wir dann auch mehr mit
traumatisierten menschen zu tun haben
und dann entsprechend auch mit
traumatisierten kindern und jugendlichen
zum teil werden diese allein auf die
reise geschickt die herausforderungen
könnten also noch größer werden nicht
nur in berlin wo nach wie vor die
meisten geflüchteten ankommen
dann werden dieses films ist peter
ruhenstroth bauer hier ins andere
deutschland studie bekommen der
geschäftsführer der uno-flüchtlingshilfe
das ist der deutsche partner des
flüchtlingshilfswerk der vereinten
nationen herzlich willkommen schön dass
ich bei
1,5 millionen geflüchtete nicht mal zwei
wochen die zahl haben wir gerade gehört
was macht diese hohe anzahl an menschen
mit ihnen das ist die größte zahl seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg richtig und das
ist die zahl von gestern abend heute
sind es 1,7 millionen es ändert sich
stündlich
dass die zahl derjenigen die schutz und
sicherheit suchen innerhalb aber auch
außerhalb der ukraine
sich auf den weg machen über eine
million menschen mittlerweile sind in
polen angekommen und natürlich hilft der
un hcr inland genauso wie in den
nachbarländern
sie kennen ja viele krisen ganz kurz
noch mal persönlich die einschätzung wie
haben sie das dann wahrgenommen die
letzten tage als sozusagen als ein
fachmann als jemand der beruflich sich
mit krisen und geflüchteten
auseinandersetzt als tragödie als etwas
was auf der einen seite fürchterlich ist
für die menschen auf der anderen seite
aber auch als gewissheit dass sich die
zivilgesellschaft in deutschland so
bereit erklärt und sich so engagiert wie
das eben jetzt der fall ist die menschen
öffnen die herzen und wir sprachen
darüber dass die willkommenskultur
praktisch weg ist und jetzt sehen wir
sie unsere entschuldigung auch unsere
zuschauerinnen und user haben dazu schon
fragen und viele sehen das auch ganz
genau so da ist die solidarität wieder
da es gibt aber eine spannende frage
auch von hasan s denn hier bei uns im
stream und zwar welche maßnahmen
vorbereitungen wurden bisher getroffen
die ankommenden kriegsflüchtlinge aus
der ukraine in deutschland zu versorgen
und in wie firmen wurden unterkünfte
organisiert gibt es da eine aufteilung
verteilung in der eu ja es gibt eine
aufteilung innerhalb der eu die eu
innenminister haben sich darauf
verständigt jetzt für ein jahr
verlängerung bis zu drei jahre neben
aufenthaltsrecht zu bewilligen und
natürlich ist das anders als das
vielleicht 2014 15 16 war insofern als
es sehr organisiert
organisiert realisiert wird das man
ankommt in einem in einer an einem
zentralen ort dass man weiter geschickt
wird in ein bundesland bis runter in die
kommune die sich dann um unterkunft und
versorgung kümmert welche vorbereitungen
haben wir ganz konkret bei uns in
deutschland vielleicht schon getroffen
die länder die städte haben schon
wunderbare vorbereitungen getroffen
jeder und jede die sich dort engagieren
wollen den kann man nur raten
unmittelbar auf die web angebote der
städte zu gehen weil man dort
beispielsweise wohnraum an anbieten kann
man kann deutlich machen was man zur
verfügung stellen will und das dann vor
ort auch tatsächlich in der stadt zur
verfügung stellen und genau daran
knüpfte auch eine frage an von birgit
münzenmaier die wir getroffen haben mit
einem unserer kamerateams mich würde
interessieren
schon anhand der bisherigen flüchtlinge
die wir aufgenommen haben wie diese
verteilung der flüchtlinge
funktioniert
also der nächste schritt
das ist dann der nächste schritt und
auch da haben sich ja die länder
geeinigt diejenigen nachdem berlin also
ein besonderer anlaufpunkt war und die
regierende bürgermeister sind da auch
sehr deutlich gemacht hat dass der bund
sich da engagieren möge haben die
bundesländer natürlich auch
entsprechende maßnahmen getroffen und
bis auf wenige die
ebenfalls bereits anlaufstellen sind für
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer diesen schutz
suchen sind alle bereit und nehmen
entsprechend auf und wenn ich als
privatperson jetzt gerne helfen möchte
was kann ich tun was ist vielleicht eine
richtige gute eine angebrachte hilfe da
gibt es zweierlei das eine ist das
wunderbare dass sie sagen ich will
helfen und ich will etwas tun und da
gibt es ganz besonderes das was an
erster stelle steht und das ist
finanzielle unterstützung für den hcr
finanzielle unterstützung die vielleicht
ein wenig kalt sich anfühlt aber
tatsächlich das wichtigste ist was es
aktuell zu tun gibt und das zweite ist
wenn ich in meiner kommune etwas tun
will in meiner stadt in meinem kreis
dann wende ich mich am besten an meine
stadt und dort bekomme ich weitere hilfe
wo ich unmittelbar etwas tun kann
ich war eine vergangenen tagen mehrmals
in berliner bahnhöfen unterwegs sie
klangen ja auch schon an eben den
beitrag und in dem was sie erzählt haben
und da habe ich auch zu jeder tages und
nachtzeit viele geflüchtete familien
ankommen sehen wobei ja familie trifft
sich wirklich denn das sind überwiegend
frauen und kinder oder eben enkel denn
die männer müssen meist in der ukraine
bleiben um eben das land zu verteidigen
so wie auch im fall von anja manu china
und ihre familie
rodina ist ukrainisch und heißt familie
der krieg der seit über einer woche in
der ukraine tobt reist tausende familien
auseinander auch anja manno china ist
mit ihren kindern nikita und milana aus
quito mir im norden der ukraine vor den
raketen geflohen die 29 jährige versucht
so oft es die telefonverbindung zulässt
mit ihrer mutter olga zu sprechen
man hört jetzt gerade die sirenen und ab
und zu hört man auch bomben aber
trotzdem geht es uns gut geht mir liegt
140 kilometer westlich von kiew mehrere
flugkörper sind in der stadt
eingeschlagen
wir werden beschossen letzte nacht haben
wir wieder schüsse gehört die schule
wurde mit raketen beschossen und ein
krankenhaus haben sie auch getroffen da
haben zum glück alle überlebt anja und
ihre kinder haben in werne zuflucht
gefunden die ungewissheit ist das
schlimmste für die junge mutter wenn ich
meiner mama gesprochen habe fühle ich
mich besser es beruhigt mich weil ich
weiß dass sie noch am leben ist ich
mache mir sehr große sorgen und vermisse
sie sehr mehrmals täglich informiert
sich anja über die neuesten nachrichten
aus ihrer heimat was ihr und auch ihrer
mutter am meisten kraft gibt ist die
europaweite solidarität mit der ukraine
wir sehen wie sehr sich die menschen in
ganz europa und sorgen wir dachten
bisher wir sind wertlos und unwichtig
für europa sie unterstützen uns und das
gibt uns kraft
anja versucht sich abzulenken so gut es
geht aber die gedanken an die familie in
der heimat beschäftigen sie
ununterbrochen
wir möchten nach hause kommen anja bitte
weine nicht ich bete dass dieser
albtraum bald vorbei ist
wir lieben euch sehr
wir vermissen
in quito mir fallen immer noch bomben
der alptraum für anja und ihre familie
geht weiter
es gibt viele hier in deutschland die
gerne helfen möchten und familien bei
sich aufnehmen wollen wir haben auch
ganz viele zuschriften per mail bekommen
da gibt es aber so eine kleinigkeit
machen da nicht nur eine kleinigkeit die
nicht gut funktioniert und zwar die
frage ist da gibt es jemand andreas er
sagt er ist frührentner würde gerne
jemand aufnehmen kann das aber
finanziell nicht stemmen oder auch jutta
wurster sie wird gern die unterkunft
anbieten bräuchte aber ein bettgestell
und einen kleinen schrank gibt es hier
finanzielle unterstützung hair & bauer
zunächst ist es mal so dass die kommunen
das selber organisieren und über ihr
webangebot man dieses angebot machen
kann ich kann ihnen jetzt nicht sagen ob
in der eigenen kommune oder in der
anderen es da noch zusätzliche
unterstützung gibt aber es wird auf alle
fälle gesammelt und jede einzelnes und
jedes einzelne angebot wird tatsächlich
dann auch geprüft und möglichst
realisiert und man kann vielen dank an
sich sie bleiben auch noch nach der
sendung bei uns dass es schön da können
wir noch mehr fragen aufnehmen sehr
gerne ganz genau und man kann natürlich
auch helfen indem man spendet wenn man
jetzt sagen ich habe gar kein platz so
leute nicht die möglichkeit jemanden
aufzunehmen dann gibt es natürlich den
menschen in der ukraine zu helfen und
auch jenen auf der flucht und zwar über
ein spendenkonto zum beispiel beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine die iba
lautet 65 und 104 106 100 104 106 100
und alle infos dazu finden sie natürlich
auch noch mal online unter spenden punkt
zdf de und
dieser krieg der dauert inzwischen schon
zwölf tage und er findet nur 1000
kilometer von uns entfernt statt er hat
auch auswirkungen auf die wirtschaft in
der ukraine bei uns in der ganzen welt
und was passiert wenn der handel mit
einander nicht mehr funktioniert das
schauen wir uns jetzt gemeinsam an
viele menschen auf dem land leben in der
ukraine und in russland vom weizenanbau
die länder gelten als kornkammer europas
wenn nicht der welt
das gelb in der ukrainischen flagge soll
für den weizen stehen das laufe den
himmel
doch was ist jetzt wo die felder nicht
bestellt werden können die handelswege
von krieg und sanktionen durchkreuzt
sind ich weiß jetzt nicht genau was wir
alles aus russland beziehen aber die
dinge wenn die knapper werdenden die
natürlich teurer werden ja auf jeden
fall wird alles viel teurer hier in
deutschland zum beispiel und die tank
preisen ist auch dass neuer geworden
aber verdienen tun mir halt nicht mehr
und deswegen habe halt immer weniger
geld im geldbeutel
ich glaube das ist nicht die große sorge
zumindest für mich nicht aber man merkt
sie schon mit ja öl gas generell auch
weizen und soja teurer weil die ukraine
ist ja die goldgrube für deutschland was
wein angeht
was wenige wissen mit am größten ist die
abhängigkeit bei sonnenblumenkernen rund
80 prozent der welternte wird
normalerweise in der ukraine und in
russland eingebracht und erreicht uns
dann zb als sonnenblumenöl in der
salatsauce
lebensmittelproduzenten sind als erster
von steigenden weltmarktpreisen im
agrarsektor betroffen die süßigkeiten
können nicht mehr zum selben preis vom
band laufen wie bisher
wir sind vielleicht auch besonders noch
betroffen insofern als russland weizen
lieferant der weltnummer 1 ist ukraine
ist weizen an bauland in der weltnummer
2 und sind natürlich auch sofort gleich
die weizenpreise dramatisch hoch
gegangen daneben steht die
energieversorgung im fokus an den
tankstellen streben die benzinpreise
weiter in den himmel zu hause steigen
beim heizen die kosten egal ob man mit
öl erdgas oder strom versucht den winter
zu vertreiben inzwischen erwartet auch
die deutsche holzwirtschaft steigende
preise
wie wird das weitergehen wenn dieser
krieg nicht so schnell aufhört und was
macht das dann mit unserer
energieversorgung wenn das russische gas
aus bleibt darüber und viele andere
themen können wir jetzt sprechen mit
professor michael hüther er ist direktor
des instituts der deutschen wirtschaft
hallo herr hüther also schön dass sie da
sind herr witte gestern hatte außerdem
auch wirtschaftsminister robert habeck
in berlin direkt bei uns im zdf von
einer herausforderung für den nächsten
winter hier bei uns in deutschland
gesprochen was ist da ihre prognose nun
ist es in der tat so wir haben bisher
einen vergleichsweise milden winter 20
21 auf 22 den sommer werden wir ganz gut
durchkommt also das hauptproblem ist gas
für die heizungen in deutschland haben
und die privaten haushalte sind auch
besonders schutzwürdig wenn man fragt
was können wir ersetzen kann man sagen
naja etwa ein drittel des russischen
gases könnten wir ersetzen über
flüssiggas das würde dann für die
privaten haushalte gelten wir bräuchten
dann aber auch eine andere verwendung
von gas oder weniger in der verstromung
also wir müssen mehr über braunkohle
mehr bei steinkohle und wir reden
deshalb auch über die verlängert um
kraftwerke über diesen nächsten winter
zu kommen das russische gas komplett zu
ersetzen das geht sicherlich nur mit
verbrauchs einschränkungen und das sind
die kopfschmerzen der
bundeswirtschaftsminister hat nicht nur
der wahrscheinlichen auch diejenigen die
bei der ezb sind zum beispiel hat ibi
gamer auf dem youtube kanal für uns
gefragt wird die inflation unter
kontrolle gebracht also eher fraglich
macht die ezb irgendwann wieder ihren
job die kann ja auch oder kann sie nicht
daran was ändern ja nein sie kann ich
wirklich was dran ändern denn was wir
jetzt erleben ist ein teuerungsschub von
der angebotsseite her ist verknappen
sich oder es werden politische
reisegesetz bei rohstoffen bei energie
rohstoffen vor allen dingen und das
treibt die inflation hoch wenn sie in
der europäischen union der europäischen
währungsunion sich die anschauen ist die
hälfte der preissteigerung durch energie
beträgt also die inflationsrate für
alles andere liegt bei 2,9 prozent das
liegt ja sieht ja schon sehr viel besser
aus was eine notenbank nicht
kontrollieren kann kann sie auch nicht
bekämpfen insofern wenn sie jetzt die
zinsen erhöhen würde würde sie ja nur
das um das risiko einer rezession noch
tun obwohl sie den eigentlichen
preiseffekt die politischen preise auf
den weltmärkten für energie nicht ändern
kann da müssen wir uns
verbrauchsgewohnheiten ändern da müssen
wir hoffen dass dieser dramatische
konflikt ein ende findet und damit neue
möglichkeiten
vielen dank damit soll die frage von
weiter reicher beantwortete eben genau
das gefragt hat bleibt die
nullzinspolitik oder muss an der
zinsfront was passieren eben gar nicht
so einfach zu machen und auch nicht so
viel spielraum wie man sich vielleicht
erhofft wir haben auch per mail noch
eine frage reinbekommen von daniela
müller sie schreibt als normaler mensch
verstehe ich nicht weshalb wir weiter
von gazprom und co gas kaufen und somit
sanktionen aushebeln und den krieg sogar
finanzieren ist es nicht möglich den
bezug sofort zu stoppen kann mir nicht
eine weile ohne diese lieferanten
rauskommen auskommen ich hatte es eben
angedeutet wenn man noch mal die zahlen
in 53 prozent des in deutschland
verbrauchten gases kommt aus russland
49 prozent der steinkohle kommt aus
russland das heißt wir haben erhebliche
abhängigkeit in diesen rohstoffen
abbestellen heißt dass wir die heizung
abstellen müssen das ist das eigentliche
problem in den industriellen bereichen
sind wir viel anpassung flexibler andere
quellen der stromproduktion zu nutzen
ich hatte es angedeutet habe der
hausbrand das macht uns wirklich
begrenzt handlungsfähig und macht dafür
umso mehr sorge die kuh 125 oder 15
fragt über youtube steht eine
finanzkrise an also das ist ja quasi die
folge frage an dessen was sie gerade
gesagt haben bzw wie hoch ist das risiko
ist es durch corona eben und jetzt den
krieg gestiegen finanzkrise die gefahr
der finanzkrise wird ja zum ausdruck
bringen dass fundamentale fehlbewertung
eingetreten sind wir haben aber hier
einen politischen vorgang eine eine ein
überfall auf ein land und ist es nicht
eine inklusion von finanzmarkt preisen
weil irgendwas da viel gegangen ist wie
vor 13 jahren an den amerikanischen
immobilienmarkt den märkten und deswegen
haben wir auch die sicherheit dass das
finanz thema stabil bleiben kann wir
haben eher die feststellung russland
wird isoliert wir haben heute gehört die
kreditkarten betreiber dem russland raus
paypal in russland raus haben die
europäische zentralbank die russische
zentralbank isoliert das sind alles
maßnahmen russland herauszunehmen aus
dem finanzsystem und damit aber auch die
krise zu isolieren deswegen eine
finanzkrise wie sie erlebt haben ist
nicht das was wir jetzt als
wahrscheinliches szenario nennen dürfen
ich schaue noch mal kurz die in die
kommentare da kommt natürlich jetzt
stetig was rein und zwar vielleicht mein
kommentar den ich hier nochmal
aufgreifen würde von bernhard schulte
der bei facebook schrieb es müssen viel
härtere maßnahmen ergriffen werden kein
öl und gas mehr aus russland wir werden
es überleben die menschen in der ukraine
nicht das kommt also jetzt doch noch mal
öfter vielleicht doch noch mal erst
darüber muss es wirklich punkt bringt
dann müssen wir verbrauchs
einschränkungen vornehmen dann müssen
wir die temperaturen die wir in unseren
heizungen den gas abhängigen heizungen
fahren runter ziehen dann müssen wir mit
dem dicken winterpullover sozusagen mit
dem pullover gegen putin dann auch
akzeptieren dass wir das tun in der
breite und insofern ist es richtig dass
politik man sagt wir gucken jetzt wie
wir in den sommer hinein alternativen
mobilisieren können es gibt von der
infrastruktur her für das flüssiggas
möglichkeiten aber halt wie viel wird
tatsächlich produziert das ist die
zweite frage da läuft jetzt auch vieles
rund und marktwirtschaften sind auch
flexibel aber jetzt da schon raus zu
nehmen ist ein wechsel auf den winter
den wird vermutlich auch die
gesellschaft noch nicht so bereit ist
einzugehen das muss man ganz nüchtern
betrachten und deswegen sind alle
anderen maßnahmen vor allen dingen die
auf die finanzmärkte die eben genannten
so wirksam und so wichtig und dass es
hat so auch noch nie gegeben historische
museen danke für ihre einschätzung herr
hüther sie bleiben nach der tv sendung
noch online bei uns und dann können wir
noch mehr fragen stellen ganz genau denn
diese sendung ist noch länger als sie
ohnehin schon ist die geht online weiter
also bleiben sie dabei gehen sie auf
unsere kanäle im zdf und wir schauen
jetzt erst noch mal auf das was herr
professor hüther gerade schon angedeutet
hat dass es eben auch einschränkungen
gibt oder teurer wird und wir alle als
bürgerinnen bürger uns darauf einstellen
müssen so wie auch christina piontek das
muss die ist nämlich berufspendler rinn
und das schon sehr lange lange hat sich
das auch für sie gerechnet rund 250 euro
im monat hat sie bislang fürs tanken
bezahlt doch inzwischen derzeit sind
mehr als 500 euro im monat man
befürchtet jetzt dass sie sich das dann
wirklich nicht mehr leisten kann
wer soll das noch bezahlen
der blick auf die zapfsäule bringt
kristina piontek aus möhnesee an den
rand der verzweiflung jeden tag fährt
sie 120 kilometer zur arbeit nach
dortmund oder ich mache mir sehr große
sorgen über die preisentwicklung weil
ich weiß nicht wo es endet und das ist
ja auch kein ende abzusehen und
es ist muss was getan also ich finde
wer sind die regierung muss sich was
einfallen lassen wie sie uns pendlern da
unter die arme greift weil wir sonst
kann ich mir bei meinen eigenen job
nicht mehr leisten christina piontek
verdient als sachbearbeiterin bei einer
krankenkasse etwa 2000 euro netto im
monat das ist deutscher durchschnitt für
die 52-jährige sind die derzeitigen
spritpreise trotzdem ein problem ich
gucke auf die zahlen ich gucke mir ein
portemonnaie auf mein
konto und denkt so naja gut
30 kannst du noch aber jetzt wird es
auch eng die spritpreise sind so hoch
wie nie doch damit nicht genug auch die
preise für strom und lebensmittel sind
gestiegen früher beliefen sich christina
und ex monatliche kosten für sprit auf
etwa 250 euro mittlerweile hat sie die
500 euro marke geknackt gespart wird wo
es geht jetzt denke ich mir dreimal ob
ich ein teures zum beispiel der kauf
oder dem osten nahm das konsumverhalten
hat sich von sehr geändert den letzten
wochen ihren job braucht christina
piontek um ihre laufenden kosten zu
decken für mehr reicht das geld
mittlerweile nicht mehr dass ich nicht
mehr so leben können wie vorher macht
mich sehr traurig weil ich habe mir
diesen neben standard aufgebaut
meine arbeit es gibt viele die haben
viel weniger im monat und müssen auch
solche strecken fahren und ich weiß
nicht wie die schaffen
autofahren ist mittlerweile luxus denn
bezahlbar sieht anders aus
das stimmt und live zugeschaltet ist es
jetzt hermann josef tenhagen
wirtschaftsjournalist und experte für
verbraucherthemen herzlich willkommen
mit den argen
hallo ich grüße sie wann haben sie das
letzte mal getankt und wie haben sie
dabei geguckt auf die zapfsäule oder aus
propan oder wohin auch immer
ich habe vorgestern das letzte mal
getankt haben 195 bezahlt und
festgestellt dass das 25 cent mehr sind
als vor drei wochen
wir haben viele fragen von unseren
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer zu das ist
das ist
dann stelle ich die frage
das ist das ist der tatsächlich auch der
unterschied also wenn man vor anderthalb
jahren hat man für einen euro 30 e10
tanken können und den tank voll gemacht
für 65 euro jetzt muss man den hunderter
aufwenden um den tank voll zu machen mit
dem gleichen mit dem gleichen sprit und
das macht natürlich für die leute schon
eine menge aus insbesondere dann wenn
man oft tanken muss und das ist auch
bundesweit so es gibt einen unterschied
beim heizöl zum beispiel gibt es riesige
preisunterschiede zwischen dem
niederrhein und zum beispiel berlin da
sind 50 cent unterschied und neben den
benzinkosten haben sie auch die
heizkosten schon angesprochenen per mail
kam die frage von dieter meier rein die
heizkosten steigen dramatisch schreibt
er sollte man dann nicht dafür sorgen
dass weniger energie verbraucht wird
müssten wir nicht viel mehr häuser
dämmen und photovoltaik aufs dach packen
gibt es dafür zuschüsse
ja also erstmal ganz kurzfristig das
kriegt man natürlich nicht kurzfristig
aufs dach ganz kurzfristig muss man
schauen dass man den verbrauch reduziert
im zweifel den wollpullover rausholen im
zweifel thermostate austauschen an den
heizungs geräten und wenn man eine
eigene heizung hat dann heißt das
hydraulische abgleich mit dem klempner
reden damit für die gleiche also für die
gleiche energie mehr bei rauskommt das
heißt weniger energie brauchen muss das
ist das was wir bei finanz tipp immer
empfehlen was man machen kann
mittelfristig oder im nächsten jahr oder
im sommer schon wenn sie ein klempner
kriegen können der eine neue heizung zum
beispiel eine wärmepumpe installiert und
eine solaranlage aufs dach super das ist
die maßnahme mit der sie putin den
stinkefinger zeigen das problem
im augenblick nicht so sehr die technik
die steht eigentlich zur verfügung
förderung gibt es eine menge wenn man
wenn sie eine ölheizung heute
rausschmeißen und so eine wärmepumpe mit
solaranlage machen würden würden sie 45
prozent förderung bekommt von vater
staat das gibt es also auch das problem
ist eher dass wir zu wenige handwerker
haben dies jetzt machen können ja und
das sein problem er will nicht sehen das
was sie gesagt haben mit dem bösen
finger und b es dauert viel zu lange
weil jetzt ist ja das entscheidende
moment auch was unsere zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer interessiert und deswegen
hier von martin c auf facebook eine
frage die sich darüber hinaus an die
lebensmittelpreise berichtet werden die
auch teurer welche haushaltsprodukte und
mittel werden sich den verknappen oder
einen preis aufstieg erleiden wo wir da
schon bei den heizkosten schon mal waren
und beim tanken
naja die lebensmittel werden in der
tendenz auch teuer das hat zwei gründe
der eine grund ist überall da wo energie
mit drin steckt also von der frage wie
wird eigentlich die tomate gezogen über
die transportfrage oder kühlketten die
eher aufrecht erhalten werden müssen da
ist jedes mal preiseffekt zu sehen und
dann gibt es natürlich bestimmte
lieferungen auch also der weizen macht
jetzt das wenigste problem ich habe
heute noch mal nachgeguckt unser haupt
weizen differenz tschechien die liefern
die hälfte ungefähr von dem weizen der
nach deutschland importiert wird und in
deutschland ist beim weizen sogar also
bei netto null wir exportieren genauso
viel wie wir importieren
wir haben noch mehr fragen noch eine
dann sind wir auch bald leider schon zum
schluss hier in dieser sendung aber eine
möchte ich noch auftreiben greifen hier
bei youtube kam die frage von memoirs
der user rein wie kann es sein dass ich
heute an der tankstelle vorbei fahre und
der diesel 2 eur 2 kostet und der super
zwei euro ist das eine folge des krieges
oder so schreibt der user der grünen
regierung
ist jedenfalls keine folge der grünen
regierung sondern ist eine folge des
krieges und es ist auch eine folge von
spekulation der
tankstellenbetreiber also mit anderen
worten der mineralölkonzerne man muss ja
wissen dass zum beispiel in schwedt und
die raffinerie die gehörte rosneft zu 90
prozent und in schwedt und auch in
sachsen-anhalt kommen
pipelines an wo russisches erdöl
angeliefert wird und es ist sehr
spannend zu gucken wie die preise
unterschiedlich sind wie gesagt im osten
ist zum beispiel der heizölpreis was ja
auch dort hergestellt wird um 50 cent
höher als an der holländischen grenze
noch eine frage per mail kam von ronald
der fragt sich müsste der staat nicht
die energiebezogenen steuern senken
damit wir auf den kosten wie stand 2021
verbleiben das würde doch helfen
also das würde den einzelnen helfen der
staat muss sicher überlegen wofür gibt
er sein geld aus und unabhängig werden
wir von putin und einfach vor allen
dingen dadurch in der stadt sehr sehr
viel geld jetzt dafür ausgibt dass wir
alle eine andere heizung eine andere
heizungs möglichkeit bekommen und zwar
schnell das ist das was uns wirklich
hilft unabhängig zu werden alles andere
ist ja im grunde ein pflaster das muss
war bei leuten die wirklich es sehr eng
haben auch machen den muss geholfen
werden mit direktem geld aber eine
langfristige lösung ist das natürlich
nicht und wie gesagt die förderung wenn
sie das machen können wenn sie ihre
heizung austauschen können machen sie
das können sie bei finanziert alles
nachlesen 45 prozent förderung wenn sie
den klempner haben den elektriker
bringen sie den an den staat jetzt
und jetzt sagen wir erstmal vielen dank
dass sie bei uns waren hermann josef
tenhagen und noch bei uns bleiben ja und
bei uns geht das jetzt nämlich nur
online weiter wir gehen also weiter hier
online live bei zdf heute hier im tv ist
zu ende aber wenn sie wollen bleiben sie
doch gerne noch da und stellen noch
weiter fragen ja und stichwort sandler
ist natürlich nur vorübergehend denn
morgen um viertel nach fünf sind wir
wieder für sie da mit hallo deutschland
auch noch mal extra lang und extra
dicker dank auch an dich alissa dass du
hier bei uns dabei weist eine premiere
und ich finde es wunderbar geklappt
danke danke dass ich da sein dürfte sehr
gern bis morgen liebe zuschauern
zuschauer
heißt das jetzt wir sind direkt online
das heißt dass der wüste haben
so war denn genau wie gewöhnlich jetzt
weiter das ist das schöne wir können
also jetzt noch ganz viele von euren von
ihren fragen aufnehmen und zurück bei
uns im studio ist jetzt nämlich michael
hüther erst der direktor des instituts
der deutschen wirtschaft und für alle
die jetzt vielleicht erst noch neu dazu
kommen stellt gerne fragen wir
beantworten sie hier mit unseren
experten experten im studio und jetzt
machen wir hier weiter es gibt einige
fragen die wir gesammelt haben noch gar
nichts trinken ein glas erhöhte hat
jemand einen glas für und gab es der
versuch geht schon ich schaue aber mal
rein denn es gab also schon viele
kommentare bei uns die wir also jetzt
über die sendung gesammelt haben und da
können wir jetzt noch mal fragen und
zwar zur wirtschaft ganz konkret möchte
gerne
c1 an sie wissen bei youtube was kann
getan werden um die steigenden preise
politisch abzufedern vorstellung
rohstoff import aus russland muss
aufhören schreibt die person ja
kurzfristig haben wir dass er deutlich
gemacht sind die möglichkeiten sehr
begrenzt also man kann sich vorstellen
dass wir noch abstellen und sagen wir
nehmen das russische gas nur das ist
durch die ukraine kommt das jetzt
natürlich besonderen charme man muss
aber wissen wenn wir auf lng gas also
dieses flüssiggas umsteigen das ist etwa
doppelt so teuer wie das russische gas
und langfristige verträge also der
preiseffekt ist zunächst einmal da und
dann gilt genau das was er tragen sagte
dann muss jeder für sich überprüfen kann
er jetzt in die investition einer neuen
heizungsanlage reingehen ist das bei ihm
möglich das hängt ja von den baulichen
dingen manchmal als luftwärmepumpen
haben bestimmten raumbedarf und
ähnliches also da sind die politischen
möglichkeiten begrenzt ich finde man
kann allerdings überlegen ob man an den
tankstellen den hohen steuer keil dem
wir drauf haben als für eine gewisse
zeit aussetzt das würde ja doch vielen
helfen die da auch einfach ja nicht
anders könnten euch die in der mobilität
gebunden sind genauso wie auch sagen wir
schützen die haushalte weil die
heizungen die von heute auf morgen
brauchen können können sie ganz kurz
danach man ergänzen vor der nächsten
frage wie groß ist dieser steueranteil
haben über zwei euro pro liter so dicken
daumen könnten versagen das knapp die
hälfte die dann beim normalen dazu kommt
das sind ja die mehrwertsteuer sind die
verschiedenen anderen steuern und
insofern ist ja auf der anderen seite
richtig dass der bundesgesetzgeber jetzt
auf den weg bringt die eeg-umlage
abzuschaffen die zahlen alle in den
strompreis ihr könnt ihr der stromsteuer
noch etwas tun also dort etwas noch
zurücknehmen aber mobilitäts und wärme
bezogen heizkostenpauschale gibt es und
bei der mobilität müsse man schauen und
ein weiteres frage jetzt über den
monitor für sie herr hüther die haben
wir nämlich gefilmt und eingefangen
hatten lust vorher im krieg mit mit
netter das ist meine angst
das ist meine frage
das ist schwierig zu hören gewesen hat
die luft für einen krieg mit wenn man
normal hören oder haben sie nicht
verstanden ich glaube was wir ja etwas
er ja erlebt ist dass sein plan nicht
aufgeht und das ist ja das was auch
internationale militärbeobachter wo ich
auch nur zur kenntnis nehmen kann sagt
die russische armee ist halt nicht in
dem zustand in dem dachte dass sie sei
das heißt ja gar nicht einsatzbereit in
der form also den konflikt über die
grenze der ukraine in die nato
hineinzutragen würde ja für ihn völlig
überdehnung der infrastruktur mit darf
eines nicht vergessen die russische
wirtschaft steht auf tönernen füßen sie
ist ein globalisierungs verlierer ist in
den letzten acht jahren seit dem beginn
der sanktionen gegen die uhr gegen die
udssr gegen die russische regierung
durch den durch die addition der krim ja
schon zu einer schwächen gekommen es ist
ja nichts entwickelt worden wir haben 80
prozent des exports sind rohstoffe es
gibt nichts interessantes was man sonst
aus russland außer kleinen dingen
mobilisieren kann es seine ressourcen
basiert die gagen ökonomie die auf
luxusprodukte sich nur interessieren
aber nichts in der gesellschaft in der
ökonomie an innovationsleistungen
mobilisiert haben und das muss man immer
mit ins bild nehmen also er würde das
gar nicht lange durchhalten also
insofern wunder nicht manche sagen ja
aber muss ja mal die was ja so sagt
ernst nehmen natürlich das ist alles
jetzt schrecklich aber man darf jetzt
auch nicht naiv sein glaubt das geht
jetzt einfach weiter
2007 bei youtube möchte gerne wissen wie
können sanktionen gezielt putin und
seinen stab treffen und nicht die
normale bevölkerung in russland ja gut
das ist ja auch neu was man früher nicht
kannte dass man die personen
identifiziert dass man ihre
vermögensbestände identifiziert die
leben ja ihren luxus nicht in russland
aus sondern in den standorten die in
europa und in den usa bekannt sind und
da greift man nun zu und was man ja im
grunde versucht ist dass dieser ganze
entourage dieses dieses ganze diese
ganze umgebung die seiner machtstruktur
dass die irgendwann die lust verlieren
und sagen jetzt aber mal gut und das ist
der eigentliche punkt ihn selbst wird
das glaube ich nicht sonderlich berühren
ob er das paar euro oder paar dollar
mehr oder weniger hat aber die
schwächung liegt in seiner und dieser
gruppierung diese oligarchen und der
anderen die zur stützung dieses systems
fungieren und das ist das ziel das wird
gemacht aber es reicht halt nicht und
deswegen die notenbank und swift und die
bezahlungssystem und all dieses
hinzunehmen
wo wir schon mal hier haben nochmal
zurück von der notenbank zu dem bild was
hinter ihnen ist die preise an den
zapfsäulen
dazu fragt liane klippert über facebook
es gab ja schon mal eine
wirtschaftskrise der wurde sonntags kein
auto gefahren wäre sowas auch noch mal
möglich ich kann mir das beim bei der
mobilität nicht wirklich vorstellen wir
haben das ja nur 273 erlebt nach dem
oktoberkrieg im nahen osten als
ursprünglicher die preise hoch gingen
und die mengen verknappt worden sind
gerät da wir jetzt hier heber nicht mehr
mengen knapp wir reden nur über preis
also wir haben eigentlich nicht das
problem auch beim mineralöl- oder die
verarbeitung das ist knapp ist beim
diesel sehen wir jetzt dass es mal ein
bisschen teurer weil viele diese
produktion in russland aus stattfindet
aber damals war es wirklich eine mengen
einschränkung das hat dazu geführt dass
wir sparen mussten da gab es diese
autofreien sonntage und man konnte
durchs ruhrgebiet über die autobahn die
a40 wandern nicht wenn wir haben noch
eine frage die wir vorher auf der straße
eingeholt haben und herren mal kurz rein
zusammen
würden die wirtschaftsexperten des so
bewerten dass sie eben zu spät auch die
sanktionen
verhängt haben das eben zu spät wahr und
sagen niemals mit ihm zusammen wird
sondern die bevölkerung
das hatten wir schon mal dabei und sie
sehen das drängt so ein bisschen
vielleicht gehen wir da noch mal darauf
ein ich glaube dass wir insgesamt
anerkennen müssen das ist aber für mehr
ökonomen auch nur einen lernprozess was
politik aus und politik in den letzten
jahren eigentlich versäumt hat dass wir
viel zu lange darauf gesetzt haben
könnte mit putin über einen normalen
rationalen dialog interessen abwägend zu
einem ergebnis kommen und insofern hat
es dazu die sanktionen nicht scharf
genug fand sie haben zwar gewirkt dass
sie jetzt aber doch sehr schnell und
glaube ich auch in der breite vollzogen
wurde nicht erwähnt dass wirklich
historisch einmalig ist also ja man
hätte sich das er vor schreck von der
mitte auch nicht so lange auf diesen
leinpfad seiner komischen historisch
verkündeten argumentation einbauen
müssen aber jetzt ist es nun mal so und
jetzt müssen wir das in der ganzen
konsequenz noch weiter denken war auch
eine frage übrigens von einem weiteren
user auf youtube das ist genau das thema
viel zu spät vielleicht und ich starke
noch auf die sanktionen geguckt wo zu
sagen ja also ich würde sagen vielleicht
zum ende dieses wirtschafts teils auch
noch mal dass es nochmal weiten da passt
nämlich auch eine frage von dieter weise
bei youtube dazu der schreibt und fragt
sich eine ganze reihe von führenden
deutschen unternehmen gibt ihren
marktanteil in russland auf wie werden
eurer meinung nach die asiatischen
hersteller dies feiern schreibt er naja
also die müssen erstmal ihre strukturen
aufbauen das ist ja auch nicht dass sie
die geschäfte gleich aufgegeben haben
man fährt das geschäft runter man
schließt man kappt die
liefermöglichkeiten in die russische
föderation um auch den bürgern klar zu
machen es gibt eine weitgreifende
solidarität auch der unternehmen das ist
ja auch normalerweise haben wir auch in
dieser form noch nicht erlebt aber klar
ist was im grunde in der frage versteckt
dass wir dürfen jetzt nicht etwas
entstehen lassen das russische
oligarchen noch mal neu entstehen weil
die mit billigen geld das beim ist er
quasi wertlos alles versuchen wieder
irgendwie vermögensbestände auch
unternehmen aufzukaufen und vielleicht
muss man gerade anders herum denken wir
müssen einfluss gewinnen wenn der rubel
da steht wo er steht vielleicht
unternehmensanteile kaufen beiseite
legen unseren einfluss erhöhen aber dass
die deutschen oder die britischen
französisch amerikanische unternehmen
jetzt ihre strukturen zurückfahren
deutlich zu machen das machen wir so
nicht mit das ist glaube ich ein
wichtiges signal das ist aber noch keine
einflugschneise für die chinesen die
chinesen kommen wir nur wenn sie ein
vorteil für geschäft dort sehen und dann
werden sie auch schon längst da und das
ist ja kein interessanter wirklich
interessanter partner auch wenn die
chinesen da ständig behaupten bis dahin
ist ja noch ein relativ weiter weg weil
wir ja gerade erst möglich am anfang
dieses krise des krieges stecken und
ganz andere probleme parallel zu lösen
sind für den moment herr hüther vielen
vielen dank dass ich länger geblieben
sind für die antworten und die hinweise
die sie uns gegeben haben und das was
sie gesagt haben mit ihren fragen
bleiben sie noch ganz kurz steht ist
auch genau das thema von marina henke
sie ist professorin für internationale
beziehungen politik an der hertie school
in berlin und ist jetzt live
zugeschaltet sie können sozusagen noch
mal fliegenden wechsel mache mit dem
herrn hüther den sie gar doch gehört
haben jetzt müssen sie quasi als
expertin für das internationale die
fragen beantworten die damit
zusammenhängen ich gebe noch mal eine
frage weiter die hütte auch schon
mehrfach thematisiert hat war das zu
spät mit den sanktionen hätte man sich
eher unabhängig machen müssen waren wir
als die uhr als deutschland zu lange
abhängig von russland und anderen
ländern vielleicht
ich glaub ja es gab einfach eine
unterschätzung oder einfach ein völliges
viel verständnis
auf was putin aus war ich mein man
konnte ja schon so ein bisschen sehen
was wir an großen die gemacht hat was
ihr an georgien gemacht hat was er dann
in syrien gemacht hat was er denn er
kriegen gemacht hat und ganz ehrlich von
einer sicherheitspolitischen perspektive
das waren sehr sehr sehr aggressive
schritte und dann zu glauben hier in
deutschland vor allem mit putin kann man
immer noch gut und es ist ein lieber
nachbar und wir verstehen uns schon fand
ich ein bisschen naiv aber was gerade
die sanktionen angeht ich glaube jedes
ganz große problem war dass die
regierung von scholz an einen
anscheinend an einem konzept geglaubt
hat und herr scholz hat das persönlich
der washington post erzählt und er hat
gesagt das heißt es stetig an be oder
strategische ambiguität spricht man sich
so ganz genau was man denn hier
überhaupt sanktionieren möchte und ich
glaube das war ein ganz ganz großes
missverständnis so eigentlich auch
einfach den missverständnis was
abschreckung überhaupt bedeutet denn
abschreckung funktioniert nur wenn man
ganz klar sagt wenn ihr das macht also
sprich hier in die ukraine einmarschiert
kann werden wie wirklich ein ganz harter
sanktionspaket vorlegen und das hat eben
die deutsche regierung nicht gemacht und
dadurch auch natürlich nicht europa und
deshalb würde ich sagen dass auf dieser
ebene große fehler begangen worden sind
unsere sendung mit ihnen im tv begonnen
mit der sorge auch was das vielleicht
für uns alle hier bedeuten könnte weil
putin ein wenig daher zündet in oder
sich ja ein wenig genau das liebe ich
zurück also es gibt die sorge auf jeden
fall vor einem atomkrieg das sehen wir
auch in den kommentaren und ich möchte
da also nehme ich eine frage per mail
die und sie jung hart so nennt er oder
sie sich gestellt hat aufgreifen und
zwar tritt der nato bündnisfall ein wenn
radioaktive strahlung durch ein
beschlossenes akw und/oder
atombombenabwurf in der ukraine in ein
nahtlos nato mitgliedsstaat eindringt
also ob das dann ein nato bündnisfall
wären
nein das ist kein nato bündnisfall nato
bündnisfall würde nur eintreten wenn
wirklich ein nato land angegriffen
werden würde militärisch angegriffen
werden würde genau
und es gibt noch viel viel mehr fragen
an sehe ich versuchte nicht den
überblick zu verlieren und zwar möchte
hier ganz dünnes eis wie youtube wissen
kann man sagen dass die russischen
truppen eher träge vorankommen und
dadurch eine gefahr für andere länder
weniger gegeben ist oder haben sie ihr
potenzial bislang nur noch nicht gezeigt
also genau das ist eine ganz spannende
frage in der tat hat hatte putin die
ukrainische dänischen widerstand
unterschätzt also sehr gibt viele
indizien dass wirklich die russische
armee die russischen generäle gedacht
haben das wird kein spaziergang ja wir
sind ein paar tagen in kiew die ukraine
werden kapitulieren und dann ist
praktisch diese kampagne vorbei und das
ist natürlich nicht eingetreten
in diesen aller ersten tagen von der
kampagne hat man dadurch auch angst
gehabt dass wenn das eben alles so
leicht ist das dann putin auf den
gedanken kommen kann jetzt habe ich hier
schon meine 150 oder sogar 170.000
soldaten versammelt dann kann ich auch
gleich weitergehen und zum beispiel
richtung moldawien jetzt nimmt man
gerade an dass es da schon ein umdenken
gab auf verschiedenen ebenen aber eben
auch ein umdenken das er putin nicht
vorhat in irgendwelche anderen er länder
anzugreifen und dass er erstmal sich um
die ukraine kümmert sozusagen aber eben
auch was die ukraine angeht neue
taktiken anwenden wird und das ist eben
vor allem eine skalierung und das ganze
also eine ganz strategische
kampagne gegen zivilisten und hier
möchte ein konzept den willen von der
ukraine brechen
wir hoffen dass es dabei bleibt dass es
eben nicht noch größer wird und ein
größerer und weiterer krieg wird so
schlimm dass bisher auch ist und aber
für diesen fall darauf zielt die frage
von sesam über youtube und der hat
gefragt wird diejenige sollte es dann
eben zu einem konventionellen krieg
kommen eben doch zwischen nato und
russland werden die chancen der allianz
eingeschätzt oder wie weit würde
russland kommen bis man sie stoppen und
zurückdrängen kann erhöht hat ja gerade
gesagt da sind gar nicht die
finanziellen mittel dabei der russischen
armee bei russland wie schätzen sie das
ein
also erstens hoffe ich wirklich und ich
denke dass nato staaten gerade alles
unternehmen wirklich alles unternehmen
dass es ebenso einer eskalation nicht
kommt die ukraine oder man sagt dass
russland 75 prozent seiner armee für die
ukraine kampagne serviert hat also in
der tat es sind gerade nur 25 prozent
noch übrig für andere abenteuer aber und
das behalte ich für ein sehr wichtig ist
aber wenn wirklich jetzt die nato
aggressiv in diesen krieg eintritt und
zb eine no fly sohn wer eine solche
aggression warum weil dann die nato in
flugabwehrsysteme bombardieren müsste
und auch
russische
kampfjets abschließen müsste das sind
sehr sehr aggressive schritte und in so
einem szenario kann ich mir vorstellen
dass die russen nicht einfach still
sitzen bleiben sondern dass es dann auch
vergeltungsschläge
ergeben kann und das heißt lange noch
nicht dass es zu einer invasion kommt
aber einfach zu gezielten
vergeltungsschlägen in dem nato
territorium oder gegen nato-truppen und
das ist die wirkliche eskalationsgefahr
gerade ich lese bei youtube bei facebook
in unseren kommentaren auch viel sorge
also von auch vielen menschen die hier
sind wir sind rund 1000 kilometer von
der ukrainischen grenze entfernt albert
viel schreibt bei facebook kann aus der
ukraine krieg unter umständen ein
gesamteuropäischer krieg werden und
falls usa nato doch eingreifen sogar der
dritte weltkrieg
die ich eben gerade schon gesagt habe
ich glaube an allen parteien und ich
weiß dass für alle nato-staaten wirklich
alles tun um das zu verhindern
und da stellt natürlich unglaublich
komplizierte moralische fragen weil so
das elend eben in der ukraine nicht
gestoppt werden kann aber ich denke dass
es eben genau das ist eben einer da
zwänge der wir uns selten müssen weil
ich denke so eine eskalation wer
wirklich ist plausibel aber die müssen
wir wirklich unter allen umständen
verhindern unsere sendung hier heißt der
ihre fragen als ihre fragen liebe user
und eure fragen userinnen und user
deswegen machen wir mal so ein
thematischen sprung war dass jetzt
wieder ein ganz anderes thema ist was
daniela müller per mail geschickt hat es
gibt noch ein paar schritte zurück es
geht um die waffenlieferung an die
ukraine warum werden die von uns so
detailliert publik gemacht das ist doch
taktisch ungeschickt der feind in
anführungsstrichen schreibt daniela
müller gehört und ließ doch mit ja aber
es geht hier wieder um abschreckung also
im endeffekt
signalisieren wir mit diesen
waffenlieferungen russland es wird nicht
so leicht deine pläne die du hast mit
der ukraine die wollen wir durchkreuzen
natürlich ist hier wieder die idee dass
auch sich etwas in russland tut dass
praktisch auch entweder generäle oder
zivilisten russland sagen komm lass uns
doch diese kampagne abbrechen weil wir
haben uns einfach verkalkuliert und das
kann so nicht weitergehen also es gibt
hier auch eben diese dieses publikum in
russland das wir erreichen wollen und
deshalb werden die publik gemacht eine
frage kommt von karin per mail dem
versuchten wir sehr nach vorne zu
schauen und fragt gab und gibt es eine
realistische chance dass die ukrainische
armee mit allen ihr zur verfügung
stehenden ressourcen den russischen
aggressor erfolgreich zurückschlagen
kann
man hat solche beispiele immer wieder
gesehen und vor allem in induktions
kriegen das war im prinzip dass
afghanistan beispiel noch unter der
sowjetunion auf eine gewisse weise war
das auch dass afghanistan beispiel jetzt
unter der nato es gibt schwächere gegner
aber in solchen innovations- kriegen
also in asymmetrischen kriegen können
die ganz schön mächtig sein aber so was
wird sich natürlich sehr sehr lange
hinziehen und kann sehr viel leid
erfordern aber ist es möglich absolut
eine weitere frage nochmal von
wasserglas auf youtube das geht auch
noch mal über die europäischen grenzen
aus wie wahrscheinlich ist es dass china
im schatten des ukraine konflikt jetzt
taiwan an greift
also bei der china frage ist sehr
komplex und sehr interessant ich denke
nicht also die kurze antwort gesicht
endlich nicht dass es zu einem angriff
auf taiwan kommt
china ist glaube ich gerade auch etwas
überrascht es scheint so als ob die
chinesen auch geglaubt haben dass putin
eben diese ukraine kampagne sehr schnell
erfolgreich beenden kann und jetzt wacht
auch china auf und realisierte so war es
anscheinend dann doch nicht und ich
glaube kinder das auch überrascht das
ist ebenso ein sanktionspaket ihm
aufgefahren wird übrigens was ich noch
hinzufügen wollte zu ihrer sanktions
debatte mit meinem vorgänger es gibt ja
auch diese sekundär sanktionen also
sprich wenn chinesische unternehmen mit
russland jetzt handel treiben kann es
sein dass dann aber die amerikaner und
auch die europäer diese chinesischen
firmen dann von europäischen und
amerikanischen märkten ausschließen also
china ist eigentlich auch hier gefragt
in diesem szenario und
von meinen kontakten in china weiß ich
dass das da gerade wirklich ein bisschen
einen frack eine große fragen gestellt
werden wie kann es weitergehen und
antworten wurden noch nicht richtig
gefunden aber ich denke wirklich nicht
dass es jetzt gerade der zeitpunkt ist
dass die taipan angreifen werden ein
geschenk für die antwort ja danke für
die antwort und wir springen leider auch
ein bisschen mit den fragen es gibt da
einfach zu viele verschiedene bereiche
die euch die sie interessieren und zwar
haben wir uns nämlich auch im vorfeld
mann auf der straße angehört und da kam
nochmal ein ganz anderer aspekt eine
ganz andere sorge und angst mit rein wir
hören mal kurz zusammen in den ton und
sprechen dann darüber
also das einzige was natürlich
beunruhigend ist denke ich jetzt auch
mal so für meine altersgruppe gerade von
den männlichen
jungen leuten wir sind im wehrfähigen
alter wir sind theoretisch auch noch
wehrpflichtige nur ausgesetzt worden und
insofern bei so einer kompletten
eskalation könnte ist uns ja auch
betreffen da mache ich mir schon
gedanken
also maximilian schmid hat das jetzt
noch mal so fern gewartet dass er sich
als junger mann in deutschland das er
sorge davor hat dass er im zweifel
vielleicht also ja auch eine wehrpflicht
wahrnehmen müsste dieses land hier
verteidigen müsste da sind die ängste
und sorgen einfach groß können sie uns
da ein bisschen einschätzung geben
ja also da sind wir wirklich noch nicht
und dem wie ich eben auch schon vorher
gesagt habe wirklich alles wird getan um
so etwas zu verhindern und deshalb
glaube ich muss ich einfach hier nochmal
ganz klar sagen ich glaube da kann man
noch ein bisschen genau da kann man noch
ein bisschen gelassener ja in diese
richtung sehen und ein besseres
schlusswort an so einem harten tag bei
so einer schweren sendung von ihnen als
expertin könnte man nicht haben vielen
vielen dank marina henkel dass sie uns
hier durch den abend durch die frage
geleitet haben und auch ein bisschen
mehr ein hauch zumindest an gelassenheit
transportiert haben live aus berlin
viele grüße und danke fürs dabeisein und
wir können jetzt hier in unserer sendung
auch noch über ein weiteres thema
sprechen was vorhin auch schon mal kurz
im tv thema waren jetzt haben wir noch
ein bisschen mehr zeit für frau und zwar
wenn wir jetzt mal ganz konkret auch
darauf schauen wie wir hier in
deutschland auch geflüchteten helfen
können es sind jeden tag immer mehr die
hier ankommen die bei uns ankommen und
dazu haben wir auch wieder herrn routen
ruhenstroth bauer von der uno
flüchtlingshilfe hier bei uns im studio
schön dass sie noch mal da sind vielen
dank willkommen zurück und wir haben
auch hier für diesen themenbereich
nochmal im vorfeld auf der straße
gefragt was sind ihre eure fragen hören
da kurz zusammen rein und wollen darüber
sprechen
meine frage wäre warum wir einen
unterschied zwischen menschen machen die
vor krieg flüchten warum bekommen
ukrainerinnen die aus der ukraine
pflichten eine andere behandlung als zum
beispiel menschen die aus syrien vor
krieg pflichten diese situation genau
die sie beschreibt das findet ja
scheinbar an den grenzen statt an den
grenzen zur ukraine haben sie darauf
eine antwort da gibt es
meldungen gerade in den sozialen medien
dass da unterschieden wird der un hcr
ist ja in den nachbarländern der ukraine
und in der ukraine selbst aktiv in der
ukraine schon seit den 90ern jetzt in
den nachbarländern an den grenzen
unterstützt dort und mein kollege chris
melzer der an der polnisch ukrainischen
grenze steht sagt dass die menschen die
gar keine papiere haben da hat es etwas
länger gedauert aber der hcr tritt
natürlich dafür ein dass alle menschen
natürlich schutz und sicherheit bekommen
die asyl beantragen und entsprechend ist
es dort dann auch erfolgt sodass diese
verzögerung die es gab dann nicht mehr
aktuell waren ich glaube was damit auch
noch gemeint ist in der frage was damit
schwangen das zu lesen wir auch online
bei uns sehr sehr häufig dass jetzt
gerade den menschen die aus der ukraine
fliehen die eine weiße haut haben da
eine größere solidarität entgegen kommt
als menschen die zuvor versucht haben zu
fliehen die keine weiße haut hatten
deckt sich das aber auch mit jetzt
erzählungen die sie von dort hören oder
wie sie darauf das deckt sich zumindest
mit nachrichten die man in den sozialen
medien bekommt aber es gilt eben das was
ich eben gerade schon gesagt habe der
unrat tritt dafür ein dass alle menschen
und er hat ja auch direkt an alle
nachbarländer appelliert die grenzen
offenzuhalten dass alle menschen die
asyl brauchen tatsächlich das dann auch
bekommen und die grenze überschreiten
können um schutz und sicherheit zu
finden und ist ja auch noch mal ein
appell von ihnen den sie eben auch schon
gemacht haben in unserer sendung die
sache mit dem großen herzen im moment
sehen wir diese wahnsinnige solidarität
und hilfsbereitschaft und die sollten
uns zumindest auch für die zukunft wenn
es auch noch mal andere fälle gibt auch
bewahren und zu sagen es geht nicht um
schwarz und weiß und aus welchem land
man flüchtet sondern das was wir jetzt
erleben solidarität dann hilfen ist ja
das was möglich ist wenn wir alle
zusammenhalten das sollten wir uns nicht
nur bewahren sondern die fälle gibt es
ja und der flüchtlingskommissar der
vereinten nationen viel programm die hat
ja vergangene woche im sicherheitsrat
darauf hingewiesen das ist eine tragödie
was in der ukraine passiert aber lasst
uns nicht vergessen syrien äthiopien
zentralafrika bangladesch an vielen
stellen in der welt sind menschen im
jemen auf der flucht und suchen schutz
und sicherheit jetzt ist es hier direkt
bei uns mitten in europa eine
herausforderung und es ist großartig wie
ich wie engagiert die zivilgesellschaft
da eintritt aber wir dürfen nicht
vergessen
84 millionen menschen sind weltweit auf
der flucht eine vorstellbare zahlen zu
sprechen das an also nicht nur aus der
ukraine flüchten menschen dazu passt von
julia hansen bei facebook die menschen
flüchten aus der ukraine flüchten auch
menschen aus nach russland moment sie
fragt ob menschen nach russland fliehen
oder weiß man das nicht aber ja ich habe
mich auch nochmal nachfragen dazu
doch es geht es gibt über die zahlen
wohin menschen fliehen gibt es ungefähre
angaben aber das wäre unseriös wenn ich
jetzt hier mit zahlen operieren würde
weil sich die zahl eben so rasant
verändert wie wir gehört haben von den
1,6 jetzt auf 17 millionen menschen die
die ukraine verlassen mussten was ich
gerne noch anschließen möchte weil das
für nicht auf spannendes flüchten ja
aber auch menschen aus russland weg die
nehme ich jetzt gerade sorge haben weil
sie sich kritisch äußern dass ihnen
etwas passieren könnte haben sie da auch
schon nähere erkenntnisse wo gehen dahin
wo werden die aufgenommen das ist ich
habe keine näheren erkenntnisse aber das
was ich mitbekomme ist eben dass
beispielsweise journalistinnen und
journalisten gerade zuhauf das land
verlassen weil eben die gefahr besteht
dass sie mit der neuen gesetzgebung bis
zu 15 jahre ins gefängnis kommen wenn
sie über die wahrheit berichten
auch krasse erkenntnisse von unseren
kolleginnen und kollegen die da eben
auch betroffen sind man sieht ja auch
bei den demonstrationen was passiert
wenn man alleine auf die straße geht
ohne groß zu berichten ich schaue noch
mal auf eine mail von harald heilmann da
geht es auch um die frage der hilfen
hier bei uns in deutschland die frage
nach dem start wer kümmert sich vom
staat aus um die flüchtlinge aus der
ukraine und auch die nachfrage dürfen
die flüchtlinge hier auch arbeiten
das ist eine ganz wichtige voraussetzung
und ja das dürfen sie
es gilt auch das was
krankenversicherungs status angeht gilt
das ebenso und das ist eine ganz
wichtige voraussetzung natürlich im
rahmen dessen was die innenminister und
innenministerin beschlossen haben eben
für ein jahr aufenthalt verlängerung bis
zu drei jahren was aber jetzt hilft ist
ganz konkret geld geld beispielsweise
für den un hcr in der ukraine
genauso wie in den umliegenden ländern
der da aktiv ist heute nachmittag ist
ein flugzeug mit
26.000 thermodecken in polen angekommen
und die sind sofort weiter in die
ukraine geleitet worden gestern sind bis
zu acht trucks innerhalb der ukraine von
den un hcr depots
befördert worden damit die hilfsmittel
verteilt werden können und das alles
kann man unterstützen über die seite der
uno-flüchtlingshilfe
zusätzlich zu den spenden gibt es auch
viele menschen die tatsächlich sagen sie
möchten jemand zu sich nach hause holen
möchten platz schaffen wohnzimmer
freiräumen oder ganze räume eben
schaffen und da passt die frage von
anton säckel die kampagne rein ich
versuche einer befreundeten ukrainischen
familie zu helfen die nach dorthin
geflüchtet ist an wen kann man sich
melden um zu klären wie sie sich in
deutschland krankenversichern können was
ist für sie jetzt außer einer unterkunft
wichtig da ist natürlich wichtig eine
unterkunft an erster stelle und eine
versorgung und jede und jeder der eine
unterkunft bereit stellt das ist
wunderbar aber bitte diese unterkunft
dann tatsächlich auch über die kommune
über die website der stadt göttingen
oder wenn sie keine entsprechende seite
eingerichtet hat was man aber im moment
jetzt feststellen kann ist dass viele
städte die es tun also über die
städtische seite in erfahrung bringen
und 1 vielleicht noch zu den
unterkünften wer eine unterkunft zur
verfügung stellt das ist großartig aber
das darf dann auch nicht nur sage ich
mal an führung für fünf tage sein oder
sieben tage sondern das sind menschen
die traumatische erfahrung wie wir in
der sendung auch schon gehört haben
erlebt haben und da kann es nicht sein
dass die jetzt in die unterkunft kommen
nach zwei wochen wieder umziehen müssen
wieder umziehen müssen das kann dann
schon auch eine längere raum von schutz
und sicherheit für diese menschen sein
was soll man da bedenken weil das er
jetzt im moment eine ganz andere phase
ist ja jetzt sieht man das leid man sagt
okay wir schaffen das aber sie als
jemand erfahren dass er seit vielen
vielen jahren sich um geflüchtete
kümmert was ist ihr noch appell an die
menschen dann zu sagen okay guckt nimmt
nachbarn mit rein und freunde
organisiert euch vorher nicht dass man
auf der strecke bleibt richtig und
wendet euch an die organisationen die
diese erfahrungen haben wendet euch an
wohlfahrtsverbände wendet euch an eure
kommune und denkt nicht an führung nur
abführung an euren ort sondern denkt
auch an die menschen in der ukraine in
dem ihr eben mit finanzieller
unterstützung denen auch hilfe gewährt
ich sage es immer wieder weil es so kalt
klingt aber tatsächlich ist das jetzt
der effizienteste und effektivste weg
vielen dank für diese einschätzung für
ihre zeit dass sie nicht so viel davon
genommen haben um unsere fragen zu
beantworten herr unstrut bauer danke
ihnen ich danke ihnen und da sage ich
auch noch mal größe von katharina
thormann über facebook liebe
zdf-redaktion und damit auch sie in
diesem moment danke für die aktuellen
informationen über den krieg und
russland der zwischen russland und der
ukraine
dass sie das hier gemacht haben also
dieses lob kam auch öfter als
redaktionen als reaktion dass wir uns
quasi diesen fragen stellten vielen
vielen dank für ihre für eure fragen
dass sie dabei waren so lange für die
einschätzung und ja es geht weiter hier
im zdf es gibt ein spezial um halb acht
dann wieder im klassischen fernsehen
oder natürlich in der zdf mediathek zdf
heute live dann geht es weiter da sind
wir natürlich morgen wieder live aber
ihr seid jederzeit immer informiert bei
zdf heute also vielen dank bis jetzt für
die fragen die aufmerksamkeit und danke
dass du auch länger für uns online
geblieben vielen vielen dank noch mal an
denen der meinen laptop gewechselt hat
dann ist jetzt wieder der saft war
wieder da muss noch mal sagen das ganze
team hier im zdf vor hinter der kamera
überall und bis bald vor auch immer
macht's gut
[Musik]